PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
I have here a little bit of
a strange problem for you.
So let me just tell it to
you, and then I'll give you
some time to work on it.
So I want to define
a function, g of x,
and I want to
define it piecewise.
So when x is positive, I just
want g of x to be 1 over x.
But when x is negative, I want
g of x to be 1 of x plus 2.
So I've got a little graph
here of the function.
So you've got, you know,
when x is positive,
it's just your usual
y equals 1 over x.
But when x is negative, I've
taken, I've shifted it up by 2.
So this is a perfectly
good function.
It's not defined at 0.
OK?
So what I would
like you to do is
to compute the derivative
of this function, wherever
it's defined.
And you'll notice, when you get
there, that you'll have some..
you'll get some answer, and
maybe you'll notice something
a little weird
about that answer.
So if you notice something weird
about it, what I want you to do
is try and explain
why this is true.
And if you don't
notice something weird,
then, you know, come back and
we'll talk about it together.
So why don't you pause the
video, go do that computation,
and think about what, if there's
something strange going on
here.
And then come back and we
can talk about it together.
Welcome back.
Hopefully you had some fun
working on this problem
and thinking about it.
So let's do the
first part, which
is just the computational part.
Let's have a go at it.
So, because this function
is defined piecewise,
when we compute a derivative, we
can just compute the derivative
on the different pieces.
So the function
isn't defined at 0,
so of course, it doesn't
have a derivative at 0.
But then we can compute a
derivative when x is positive,
and we can compute a
derivative when x is negative.
So when x is bigger than
0, g prime of x, well,
that's just d over
dx of 1 over x.
So that's something
we're familiar with.
Its minus 1 over x squared.
So that's for x positive.
When x is less than 0, g
prime of x is d over dx of 1
over x plus 2, because
that's what g of x is.
And, OK, and so this is,
well, the plus 2 gets killed,
and so then we have the
derivative of 1 over x.
That's minus 1 over x squared.
So one thing you've noticed
is that this is minus 1
over x squared here, and it's
minus 1 over x squared here.
So although we defined
this piecewise,
we could, we can
summarize this by saying,
so the derivative is minus
1 over x squared always,
so for all x not
equal to-- you know,
it doesn't have a
derivative at x equals 0.
It's not defined at 0, it
can't have a derivative there.
So, but we don't need the
piecewise definition, anymore.
So that was kind of
interesting, that we
can summarize the derivative
of this piecewise function
in a non-piecewise way.
Now, the thing is, we've
learned what the anti-derivative
of this function is.
So we know that the
anti-derivative of minus 1
over x squared dx is 1
over x plus a constant.
So we know that the functions
whose derivative is minus 1
over x squared are of the
form, 1 over x plus a constant.
The thing is, this function
g that we just talked about,
this function g
isn't of that form.
Right?
You don't get this function
by taking the function
1 over x and just
shifting it up or down.
You-- something weird happens.
You've shifted it
up on one piece
and not on the other piece.
And yet, it's still true
that the derivative of g
is equal to minus
1 over x squared.
So this is a little bit
of a head-scratcher.
And I wanted to talk
about why this happens.
And the thing is that there's
a sort of theoretical reason
for this, which is
that you remember
that the reason that we know
that anti-derivatives have
this form, a function
plus a constant,
is because we know
that constants
are the functions
with derivative 0.
And so we were able to apply
the mean value theorem in order
to show that if two functions
have the same derivative, then
they differ by each other,
differ from each other
by a constant.
If two functions have
the same derivative,
they differ by a constant.
And we used, as a really
crucial step in that proof,
the mean value theorem.
Now the thing is, the
mean value theorem
has, as one of its assumptions,
as one of its hypotheses,
that the functions that
you're working with
are continuous
and differentiable
in some interval.
OK?
So what's happened here is
that the functions that we're
talking about, the function 1
over x and the function minus 1
over x squared,
those functions are
continuous and differentiable
on certain intervals.
So if we look-- if we
go back to this picture
here we see that this function
g of x, just like the function 1
over x, it's continuous and
differentiable for positive x,
it's continuous and
differentiable for negative x,
but at 0, there's
a discontinuity.
So there's no
interval that crosses
0 on which this function is
continuous or differentiable.
As a result, the
mean value theorem
can't tell us anything about
intervals that cross 0.
So if the mean value
theorem doesn't tell us
anything in that case, it
means the conclusion isn't true
and we get a situation-- sorry.
I should rephrase that.
It means the conclusion
doesn't have to be true.
Our proof doesn't work in a case
where we have a discontinuity.
And what happens,
in fact, is right
what we have here, which is that
when you have a function that
has a discontinuity and you look
at its anti-derivatives, what
you can do is that, in addition
to shifting the whole thing up
and down, you can
shift the pieces
on either side of the
discontinuity separately.
Just like in this case
we can shift the piece
to the left of 0 separately
from the piece to the right of 0
and get a function whose
derivative is still
what we started with.
So this function g of x, we
get by shifting part of 1
over x up, and it gives us a
function whose derivative is
still minus 1 over x squared.
So this is true anytime
you have a function
with a discontinuity.
So one consequence of this--
I'm going to go back over here
and just write down one special
case of this-- is that to say,
we say that the
anti-derivative of 1 over x dx
is equal to ln of the
absolute value of x plus c.
What this really means is
that when x is positive,
we have a single kind
of anti-derivative,
and they're of the form,
ln x plus a constant.
And when x is negative, we
have a single anti-derivative,
that's-- or single family
of anti-derivatives,
of the form ln of
minus x-- remember,
absolutely value of x is minus
x when x is negative-- plus c.
But if we consider x to
be positive and negative
at the same time,
the two constants
don't necessarily have to agree.
You can have the same
situation that you
had before where one side can
shift up and down independently
of the other, because there's
that discontinuity at 0 there.
So this is just something
to keep in mind.
It also means you
have to be careful
with certain substitutions.
You don't want to
do substitutions
that have discontinuities.
If you do substitutions
that have discontinuities,
you might accidentally
introduce a discontinuity
and bad things can happen
that I won't go into now.
You can make-- end
up with statements
that don't make any sense by
making a substitution where
the function that
you're substituting
has a discontinuity in it.
So you-- or another
way of saying it is you
have to restrict to some
interval on which it really
is continuous.
And then on each of those
intervals it makes sense,
but bad things could
happen when you
cross those discontinuities.
So this is a little
bit theoretical,
but I think it's a nice
thing to be aware of,
a nice thing to keep in
mind when you're working
with some of these expressions.
So I'll end there.